So why do we need computer architecture? We
need it if we want to improve performance
for some definition of performance, which can be
speed at which the computation is going on, battery
life, the overall size of the computer, its
weight, energy efficiency, and so on. So we want
one or more of these to become better
than before. And another reason why we want computer
architecture is to improve some abilities of
the computer, such as adding 3D graphics support,
adding debugging support so developers can develop more
bug free programs, improving security, et cetera. So
this is about making computers faster, smaller,
and cheaper. And this is about making new
things possible. We do these by taking improvements
in fabrication technology and in circuit designs and
figuring out how to translate that into faster, lighter, cheaper, more
secure, et cetera. So this is where we need computer architecture.